Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is our 200th episode, so I know you're
expecting something great.
See how you like this one!
One of the most sought after effect in light
transport simulations is capturing indirect
illumination.
This is a beautiful effect where the color
of multiple diffuse, matte surfaces bleed
onto each other.
And of course, computing such an effect is
as costly as it is beautiful because it requires
following the path of millions and millions
of light rays.
This usually means several hours of waiting
time.
There have been countless research papers
written on how to do this in real time, but
the limitations were often much too crippling
for practical use.
But this time around, you will see soon that
these results are just outstanding, and we
will have a word on limitations at the end
of this video.
The key contribution of this work is that
instead of computing the light transport between
all possible point pairs in the scene, it
uses radiance probes that measure the nearby
illumination, and tries to reconstruct the
missing information from this sparse set of
radiance probes.
After that, we place a bunch of receiver points
around the scene to places where we would
like to know how the indirect illumination
looks.
There are several things to be taken care
of in the implementation of this idea.
For instance, in previous works, the hierarchy
of these sender and receiver points was typically
fixed.
In this new work, it is shown that a much
sparser set of carefully placed radiance probes
is sufficient to create high-quality reconstructions.
This seemingly small difference also gives
rise to a lot of ambiguous cases that the
researchers needed to work out how to deal
with.
For instance, possible occlusions between
the probes and receiver points need special
care.
The entire algorithm is explained in a remarkably
intuitive way in the paper, make sure to have
a look at that.
And, given that we can create images by performing
much less computation, with this technique,
we can perform real-time light simulations.
As you can see, 3.9 milliseconds is a typical
value for computing an entire image, which
means that this can be done with over 250
frames per second.
That's not only real time, that's several
times real time, if you will.
Outstanding!
And of course, now that we know that this
technique is fast, the next question is: how
accurate is it?
As expected, the outputs are always compared
to the reference footage so we can see how
accurate the proposed technique is.
Clearly, there are differences, however, probably
many of us would fail to notice that we're
not looking at the reference footage, especially
if we don't have access to it, which is the
case in most applications.
And note that normally, we would have to wait
for hours for results like this.
Isn't this incredible?
There are also tons of more comparisons in
the paper, for instance, it is also shown
how the density of radiance probes relates
to the output quality and where the possible
sweet spots are for industry practitioners.
It is also tested against many competing solutions.
Not only the results, but the number and quality
of comparisons is also top tier in this paper.
However, like with all research works, no
new idea comes without limitations.
This method works extremely well for static
scenes where not a lot of objects move around.
Some movement is still fine as it is shown
in the video here, but drastic changes to
the structure of the scene, like a large opening
door that remains unaccounted for by the probes
will lead to dips in the quality of the reconstruction.
I think this is an excellent direction for
future research works.
If you enjoyed this episode, make sure to
subscribe and click the bell icon, we have
some more amazing papers coming up, you don't
want to miss that.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!